[Music]
let's talk about red tails as I said
congratulations the movies doing great
people really like the film and it's
terrific and it is about the Tuskegee
Airmen that's right this is the this is
at a time on an unheard of idea right it
was a segregated military in 1943 when
they actually were first went over to
Italy ramitelli airbase was an all-black
airbase and because it was segregated
there was a certain part of the military
that didn't want them involved in the in
the military at all and in the war
effort at all so they warmed up you know
practicing for months and and becoming
basically aces and then when they
actually did join the war effort they
were you know shooting down the Germans
yeah and what's amazing is that people
at the time were so ignorant there was
this belief that well they can't they
can't make good fliers they can't be
good air men that's not going to work
and this is the story of them proving
that not only could they they were
better than anybody that's right there
was a situation where they were having
the b-17 b-24 bombers being shot out of
the sky because they're big planes you
know and each plane carried maybe 20
crewmen and they had bomber escorts so
they had these fighters who would fly
and kind of fight the Germans but it
would leave them you know exposed and
the Tuskegee Airmen's order with a stick
with the Bombers and as a result of that
their record of bomber escort was
impeccable and they they saved a lot of
men in the war effort so uh they were
looked at as heroes and got a lot of
accommodations for what's fascinating by
this film first of all you don't have to
I know you that you've depicted Tuskegee
Flyer before right in your career this
time around you didn't have to actually
get in the planes and fly around a lot
right that you don't have scenes like
that which might be a relief
I would I would not want to be well once
in applying you know if you're a pro if
you're a professional pilot and you're
told to take an actor up and let them
feel what you do to appreciate what you
do they would try to make you throw up
yeah a lot right so III it's a point of
pride with that it's a point of platinum
a Cuba Gooding jr. throw up that's right
and so I was just aim at the back of the
head yeah
[Laughter]
George Lucas spent his own money quite a
bit of his own money making this film
and so this was a real passion project
for him
yeah really real big passion project and
when you see the movie it is a big
action movie and he was concerned that
it wasn't enough of an education so he
also paid for a documentary called
double victory which is about the the
more of their detailed exploits so but
he's real passionate about this you can
see he's talking about it and now ya
asked us to promote it no we are glad to
have you we have a clip here and what
can you tell us that not a damn thing
what was your question what we do how
well we do it doesn't matter then you
offer up what you'd sign up you get
shiny boots a uniform and that'd be the
end of a hundred years of bigotry your
colored men and the white man's army
it's a miracle you're flying fighters in
Italy and not mopping latrines in
Milwaukee any of you feel otherwise
anything you wanna wash yourselves out
all Negro please do so now I'll have you
on the next thing smoking back home and
to make room for the men who want to
stand and fight get your head up son
your fighter pilots
[Applause]